Sancerre Thriller mission aiya never is
the security come with that Shania
the jeweler is here actually he's
following me everywhere
all right good night last time I saw you
it was right after opening night of your
residency he performs hard you've
partied hard you celebrated how has it
been continuing has it been a marathon
has it been amazing how are you it's
amazing
Las Vegas is a it's a privilege it
really is the technology the lighting
the theater the fans it's a wonderful
city it's a community of just
entertainment industry have you gotten
to see other show Kenny shows all the
time that's what I do on my days off I
ride horses and I go I see everyone
coming through town and I go through the
other residences as well I make more are
the artists friends in Las Vegas Jonas
Brothers coming you gonna check those
boy yeah I just love them I've been a
fan for years so we have a mutual love
so it's all in good humor and I think
it's just this is what entertainment is
all about you're not having fun and
keeping keeping a laughing at all
tonight he's won a SAG Award he's won a
Golden Globe and he's so funny in his
speeches what I'm gonna love is if he
then wins an Oscar and says in his
speech Shania Twain do a quick fashion
fill in the blank with you okay okay
number one three hours ago I was only
wearing one secret to my look is look at
sugar face scrub like this look or like
beauty I just in general
oh my no the skin is glowing it's doing
really the designers deserve all the
credit I have the Muller jewels on I
mean just stunning and I have Christian
Siriano most random thing I have with me
is hair pins no those are essential I
know I don't normally carry their beads
around by the way do you know how much
you're wearing tonight we do we have a
carat weight or anything I wish I could
tell you these are very rare this is a
ballerina cut by the way it's very
special can you see the little it's
about that
it's a ballerina cut shape it's very
special so I feel very spoiled and very
lucky we are lucky to talk to Chanel yet
thank you or just thank you so good to
see you
[Music]